2 avion libyen abattu par les américains
en méditerranée
la tension monte kadhafi jure de
riposter
airbus se gagne sur les terres de boeing
une grosse compagnie américaine la brani
achète 100 airbus
robert vigouroux ne devrait pas éviter
l'exclusion du ps
il a maintenu sa candidature à la mairie
de marseille
les prix de taizé 33 mille jeunes à
paris hier soir pour prier parmi eux
beaucoup de chrétiens des tablettes
bonsoir l'incident a eu lieu ce matin en
méditerranée des avions américains et
libyens se sont affrontées deux mig
libyens ont été abattus fait l'étincelle
que tout le monde redoutait ou en
méditerranée où la tension s'était
installée depuis quelques jours kadhafi
tonnes et menaces washington plaide la
légitime défense moscou protestent et la
france tente de calmer le jeu nous
allons y revenir mais tout de suite vous
propose de voir ce qui s'est exactement
passé ce matin au large de la libye
jacquat bouchard le nouvel incident
américano libyen s'est déroulé dans les
eaux internationales au nord de la ville
de tobrouk non loin de la frontière
entre la libye et l'egypte
il a donc opposé deux chasseurs f 14
tomcat à 2023 lydien les f 14
il y avait décollé du porte-avions de la
sixième flotte jf kennedy effectué une
patrouille de routine dans les eaux
internationales
devant l'attitude menaçante selon
washington des mig libyen les f 14 ont
tiré quatre missiles
deux parachutes déployer donc d
vu par les pilotes américains après la
chute des mets cet accrochage n'a rien à
voir avec toutes ces spéculations sur
lui cindy bien de produits chimiques a
déclaré le secrétaire à la défense car
locci devant la presse au pentagone
même son de cloche au département d'état
dans le porte parole a réaffirmé
l'inquiétude de washington au sujet de
cette fameuse usine qui pourrait
fabriquer des gaz de combat quoi qu'il
en soit l'avertissement américain est
clair à quelques jours de l'ouverture à
paris de la conférence sur les armes
chimiques
si l'usiné mise en production elle sera
détruite car comme l'a souligné
sénateurs laisser des gaz de combat
kadhafi reviendrait à laisser lance
flamme entre les mains d'un pyromane ce
grave incident étant en tout cas la fin
de l'opération de relations publiques
menées par le colonel kadhafi depuis
plus d'un an vis-à-vis des pays
occidentaux depuis 86 date de l'attak
américaines sur tripoli et sur benghazi
le bouillant colonel s'était beaucoup
calmé voici maintenant un nouvel épisode
dans le lourd contentieux entre la libye
et les états unis
martine laroche joubert
le troisième affrontement entre les
chasseurs de la flotte américaine et les
libyens la première fois outre 81 combat
en méditerranée entre la sixième flotte
et l'aviation libyenne
suite à retardement des attentats de
rome et vienne en décembre 85 attribué
par les etats-unis à la nuque
deuxième choc les 24 et 25 mars 1986
batailles navales dans le golfe de sears
ont revendiqué par les libya 58 morts de
leur côté selon tripoli
dix jours plus tard une bombe explose à
berlin ouest dans une discothèque
fréquentée par des amis du cas de morts
des dizaines de blessés
la piste qui viennent ce pré sident 15
avril
la riposte brutale 18 bombardier america
d'école de grande bretagne
objectif tripoli et benghazi 37 morts 93
décès pour les états unis la lybie est
un petit démon qui al'avantage d'être
tout à la fois très visible dans ses
actions est en fait très vulnérable la
libye apparaît favoriser le terrorisme
expansionniste par rapport à ses voisins
en afrique et au moyen-orient et elle
est en même temps vulnérables parce
qu'elle est isolée l'urss ne la soutient
pas pleinement kadhafi n'est guère
apprécié par ses collègues du monde
arabe et plus facile d'agir sur la libye
que de le faire par exemple sur la syrie
donc les etats-unis montrent ainsi leur
puissance ils montrent leur puissance si
j'ose dire à bon marché sans trop de
risques sans déstabiliser le système
international et sans encourir trop de
critiques menace attentat représailles
toute l'histoire américano libyenne le
colonel kadhafi ici dans sa maison
bombardée en 1986 déclare aujourd'hui
nous répondrons au défi par le défi oui
en fait je vous le disais tout à l'heure
la tension monte depuis plusieurs jours
dans cette région du monde en libye par
exemple il y avait eu des manifestations
de centaines de personnes
on croit qu'ils protester contre la
politique américaine bien sûr il défilé
dans les rues de tripoli
ce soir kadhafi réagi très violemment il
a décidé d'abord de porter plainte
auprès du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies et puis le colonel a
affirmé qu'il répondrait au défi par le
défi gilles rabin a interrogé tout à
l'heure son représentant c'est-à-dire
l'ambassadeur libyen en france
égoutter même dans les déclarations
américaines et on n'a pas attendez dire
que les aviateurs le pilote libyen ont
ouvert le feu ou faire quoi que ce soit
ils disent qu'il y est ils viennent un
grande vitesse et la conduite et
signifie pas réellement une préparation
une attaque qui parle aussi de délit de
provocation à deux reprises et de radars
d' attaque déclenchée mais qui provoque
qui je crois qu'elles ne sont pas à la
côte américaine ne sont pas allés du
côté américain ils sont venus
notre cote la libye a été toujours servi
comme un bouc émissaire
je crois qu'il n'est plus possible
d'utiliser l'alibi réellement comment
nouveau commissaire quelle sera la
réponse libyenne à une attaque
américaine se racheta par exemple chez j
dc s'ils sont attaqués sont ils sont
obligés c'est un devoir de le défendre
sous est d'abord il n'y a aucune raison
de quel droit les états unis attaquent
une usine libyen que la libye des
classes et une usine pharmaceutique et
qu'elle est prête réellement à recevoir
des experts internationaux pour
l'unicité
voilà donc la réaction libyenne par la
voix de son ambassadeur moscou de son
côté condamne vivement la tacc
américaine et souhaite que cette attaque
soit condamnée par la communauté
internationale à washington toujours le
département d'état a affirmé avec force
qu'il n'y avait aucun lien entre
l'incident d'aujourd'hui hélas faire de
l' usine d'armes chimiques jacques à
bouchehr leur apporter tout à l'heure
depuis quelques semaines en effet les
américains envisager une intervention
militaire contre cette fameuse usine de
rapt à une usine qui pourrait produire
des armes chimiques et qui se trouve
justement sur le territoire libyen en
fait c'est sans doute la tension
provoquée par cette affaire qui a
entraîné l'incident cette usine provoqué
déjà beaucoup de remous dans tous les
pays occidentaux car certains comme la
france et l'allemagne auraient fourni du
matériel pour construire une usine
patrice pollet et philippe rochot en
allemagne
des passerelles des canalisations qui
courent taux plafond des robinets une
citerne
lusine de rapt a filmé par la télévision
libyenne les américains affirme toujours
que c'est un complexe chimique capable
de produire des gaz de combat pour les
libyens
c'est un complexe chimique mais pour
fabriquer des produits pharmaceutiques
en tout cas pour les américains
plusieurs pays auraient participé à sa
construction en france la société de
dietrich est accusé d'avoir fabriqué sa
et réservoirs pour la libye en fait des
réacteurs en acier vitrifiés émaillé
spécialement conçues pour résister aux
acides les plus corrosifs de dietrich
avant un millier par an dont 70 % à
l'exportation de gros clients achètent
mais aussi des occasionnels comme amazon
chimie en allemagne fédérale les chez de
dietrich
on se défend d'avoir un jour ou l'autre
travaillé pour la libye n'ont jamais
vendu un réacteur lui-même à boulons en
libye je vais vous donner un exemple de
ce qu'il s'est passé
supposons que de fabrication des
bouteilles en verre nous les vendons
plus âgées ou l'acheteur paie met dedans
soit de l'eau soit du lait soit du style
soit 1 à 6 soit du poison c'est lui qui
est responsable de ce qu'il remplit la
bouteille ou non n'ont fourni que
l'emballage vide
de l'autre côté de la frontière en
allemagne fédérale
ce technicien qui tient à garder
l'anonymat accusent documents à l'appui
les britanniques les suisses les
japonais les sud coréens et les français
d'avoir participé en connaissance de
cause à la construction de lusine
libyenne pour les officiels allemands
rien ne prouve l'implication de la
société et mme rosen dans cette affaire
pas de preuves de l'implication
d'entreprises allemandes dans la
construction de l'usiné chimique de rapt
à monsieur venture le ministre des
affaires étrangères est formel il
affirme que les soupçons américains ont
été examinées mais sans résultat en
trois jours pourtant une centaine de
témoins et d'informateurs ont été
interrogés et une cinquantaine de
perquisitions faites aux domiciles
privés d'ingénieurs ou de chefs
d'entreprise
le directeur dit mao dun chibi montrée
du doigt dans la sphère réaffirme qu'il
n'a conclu aucun accord avec la libye
les reconnaît s'être rendu sur place
pour étudier l'implantation d'une usine
de polyéthylène en 81 le directeur des
finances de fribourg chargé de l'enquète
affirme qu'il n'a rien trouvé de
compromettant les reconnaît ne pas
pouvoir contrôler l'activité des
sociétés mères de hong kong ou du
liechtenstein
cette affaire s'ajoute à l' enquête
ouverte contre cinq entreprises qui
auraient livré du matériel chimique à
l'irak
elle oblige les allemands à mettre de
l'ordre dans leurs exportations
chimiques mais aussi nucléaire avec
cette question subsidiaire à toute cette
affaire est ce que cet incident
américano libyen va compromettre la
conférence qui s'ouvre samedi à paris
140 pays réunis pour tenter d'interdire
justement larmes chimiques genre
bourjolly à poser cette question aux
relents du mal nice français des
affaires étrangères monsieur dumas
souhaite que la tension ne monte pas en
méditerranée bien sûr et que l'ordre du
jour de la conférence de paris ne soit
pas modifiée la presse se suit avec une
attention très soutenu les conséquences
qui peuvent résulter de cet incident lui
même elle souhaite que la tension ne
monte pas en méditerranée et le parti le
pays hôte qui va recevoir la conférence
internationale de paris espère et
souhaite également que cette conférence
ne déviera pas de ce nombre du jour
voilà donc ce qu'on pouvait dire sur ce
dossier américano-libyen le reste de
l'actualité maintenant le père noël est
passé pour airbus l'année commence en
fanfare pour l'avion européen une
compagnie américaine la brani a décidé
d'acheter santé rebus à 320,50 ferme
cinq ans dans l'option une commande de
21 milliards de francs pour les quatre
pays qui fabrique airbus pour la france
donc c'est un gros coup de pouce pour le
commerce extérieur
gérard leclerc
52 perdu 102 retrouver au moment où la
panam annuler un contrat de 50 airbus
a320 une autre compagnie américaine
l'abrasif en achètent sans la moitié
ferme l'autre en option montant du
contrat 21 milliards de francs d'un des
plus gros jamais enregistré par le
consortium européen et qui porte à 700
les commandes de l'a320 à raison de huit
appareils sortant chaque mois des
chaînes une cadence qui vient déjà
d'être accélérer la brani fera forte
l'équivalent de 15 mois de travail aux
ateliers de construction airbus
industrie profite ainsi de la santé
financière retrouvée des compagnies
américaines et du boom du marché mondial
du transport aérien en progression de
près de 10 % l'an pour conforter sa
place de dauphin derrière l'intouchable
boeing françois mitterrand persister
répète le président de la république a
réaffirmé avec vigueur tout à l'heure la
nécessité de préserver le droit des
immigrés comme il l'avait été le 31
décembre c'était cet après midi à
l'elysée au cours de la cérémonie
traditionnelle des voeux aux corps
constitués
bernard pradines
la défense des droits de l'homme pour
monsieur mitterrand doit être un combat
quotidien
devant les représentants de la haute
administration il rappelle une règle
d'or
l'état doit faire respecter les droits
politiques le droit d'asile par exemple
les droits économiques défense de
l'emploi égalité de traitement des
femmes les droits sociaux enfin le chef
de l'état indique qu'on ne transige pas
sur ces choses et il enfonce le clou en
citant à nouveau l'exemple des immigrés
la solidarité nationale doit également
s'appliquer à eux en posant le problème
des immigrés j'ai voulu que l'on vérifia
de quelle façon été mise en oeuvre le
droit des gens chez nous et de quelle
manière était respecté nos propres
principes et que l'on en tire à et sur
le plan législatif et sur le plan
réglementaire les conclusions qui
s'imposent
auparavant devant les ministres qu'il
recevait sans doute plus facilement que
l'an dernier
le chef de l'état avait rappelé que la
tâche du gouvernement était loin d'être
terminée y compris sur le plan
international françois mitterrand
ensuite reçu les voeux du corps
diplomatique à cette occasion il a
révélé qu'il avait proposé à ses
partenaires du sommet des sept une
concertation d'experts sur le terrorisme
une concertation approprié entre les
experts compétents pour renforcer les
mesures de protection et de lutte contre
le terrorisme
robert vigouroux le maire de marseille
n'appartient plus au parti socialiste il
s'en est exclu lui-même cet après-midi
en effet il était entendu cet après-midi
par la commission électorale du ps et il
a maintenu sa candidature à la mairie de
marseille à sa propre succession
or le parti socialiste vous le savez
soutient la candidature de michel pezet
sanction immédiate pour monsieur
vigouroux il sera exclu
roland sicard même à paris robert
vigouroux fait recette déploiement de
force médiatique cet après midi pour la
convocation du maire de marseille au
siège du parti ce siècle et le ps ne
plaisante plus robert rigaud a dû
batailler pendant près de deux heures
devant la commission électorale du parti
et malgré les avertissements le maire
sortant maintient ses positions
ils contestent toujours la désignation
de michel pesé par la fédération
socialiste des bouches-du-rhône et reste
candidat à sa propre succession depuis
le départ qu'une clarification de la
situation
de la fédération des bouches du rhône
était nécessaire au préalable
voilà les alliés de savez je ne je n'ai
pas changé d'avis en venant à paris je
retourne vite à marseille parce que j'ai
du travail et y faire et d'être exclu
une commission chaque chose en son temps
chaque chose en son temps en fait le
bureau exécutif du ps réunis à huis clos
devrait exclure dès ce soir robert
vigouroux
une décision qui est loin d'être une
surprise et qui pourrait même renforcé
ses positions
le maire de marseille cultive depuis
longtemps son image anti politicienne
rien de plus logique à ce qu'ils fassent
désormais campagne sans parti politique
à gauche dans l'optique de la
préparation des municipales toujours le
pc et le ps sont rencontrés ce matin
qu'ils se reverront demain mais les
négociations semblent difficiles au
conseil des ministres ce matin on a
beaucoup parlé économie le premier
ministre et le président de la
république ont confirmé leur volonté de
poursuivre une politique de rigueur tant
en matière budgétaire que monétaire
objectifs notamment continuer la
politique de baisse des taux d'intérêt à
ce même conseil une bonne nouvelle pour
les provinciaux le gouvernement a décidé
de débloquer une enveloppe de 2
milliards de francs pour les transports
urbains de province
un nouvel épisode dans la sphère de la
société générale la caisse des dépôts
vient de se faire rappeler à l'ordre par
les parlementaires chargés de la
surveiller la caisse des dépôts qui
brasse beaucoup d'argent puisqu'elle
gère par exemple l'argent des caisses
d'epargne la caisse des dépôts s'était
engagé dans ce dossier ambiguë de la
société générale rappelle de toute la
sphère claire chazal à l'origine de la
polémique autour de la caisse des dépôts
une société très discrète mars aux
investissements dirigée par georges
pébereau partis à l'assaut de la société
générale marceau affirme aujourd'hui
détenir 10 36% de la générale mais avec
quelques amis au premier rang desquels
la caisse des dépôts bras séculier du
ministère des finances pour un tiers de
l'investissement total
la question se pose alors la caisse des
dépôts ne sortait pas de son rôle en
participant selon certains os
dénoyautage de privatiser elle qui a
pour vocation de gérer le plus sûrement
possible le bas de laine des français
est de stabiliser le capital des grandes
entreprises françaises
et puis peut-on laisser un directeur
général quasi inamovible nommé par le
président de la république diriger seule
la plus grosse banque du monde dont le
bilan dépasse aujourd'hui le budget de
la france la commission de surveillance
de la caisse présidée par le député
socialiste christian pierret est
composée de parlementaires répond
aujourd'hui clairement non elle entend
user de tous les pouvoirs que lui
confère la loi et éventuellement opposer
son droit de veto aux décisions
stratégiques prises par le directeur
général ainsi s'ouvre une brèche dans le
pouvoir séculaire de la caisse des
dépôts avec sans aucun doute l'aval du
ministère des finances qui en profitent
aujourd'hui pour blanchir son rôle dans
une affaire société générale qui a
jusqu'ici eu bien mauvaise presse
nouvelles craintes d'attentats
terroristes en italie les brigades
rouges ont brusquement réapparues alors
que depuis plusieurs mois il était en
sommeil
elles ont tenté d'enlever hier soir un
responsable de la prison de rome
cette prison sont justement des tenues
de nombreux brigadistes agnès poirier
l'enlèvement avait été minutieusement
préparé le vice directeur de la prison
de rebibbia regagnait reçoit son
domicile la route est en travaux la
voiture doit ralentir
c'est à ce moment là que quatre jeunes
gens armés tentent d'enlever et djigueul
et luca il résiste un des gardes du
corps ouvre le feu depuis une autre
voiture et quatre inconnus s'enfuit les
looks a blessé à la jambe et transporté
à l'hôpital ses jours ne sont pas en
danger
les auteurs de l'attentât se réclament
des nouvelles brigades rouges fin
octobre les 5 chef historique de
l'organisation terroriste détenu à la
prison de rebibbia ont affirmé abandonné
la lutte armée
deux mois plus tard un tract annoncé la
création d'une nouvelle formation
elle a signé hier soir son premier
attentat
en chine les incidents qui oppose les
étudiants chinois aux étudiants
africains ne cesse de s'étendre une
touche maintenant quatre villes
chinoises et les autorités de pékin
s'apprêterait à expulser des étudiants
noirs
il s'agit d'une série d'incidents
racistes qui se renouvelle depuis
plusieurs semaines éclaircissements sur
cette affaire jean marc queloz
ses vitres sont celles des dortoirs
réservé aux étudiants africains de
l'université de nankin après l'assaut
lancé veille de noël par 5000 étudiants
chinois à l'origine d'ailleurs un
incident raciale dans un dancing
mais surtout le ressentiment à l'égard
d'africains doté de bourses
d'enseignement trois fois supérieure à
celle des étudiants chinois déjà
mécontents de leur sort matériel
xénophobie latente puis racisme
un journal local dénoncer je cite les
diables noirs porteurs de sida ni à du
racisme ici déjà si ce n'est moi comme
ça j'ai fermé les six classes depuis le
début des heurts le gouvernement chinois
restent remarquablement muet alors même
que les manifestations racistes se
propage et que l'organisation de l'unité
africaine crie au scandale
quatre étudiants africains arrêtés
d'autres battues peut-être des
expulsions décidément l'amitié
indéfectible entre la chine et les
peuples frères d'afrique vient de
prendre un sacré coup de bambou
je vais aller à shanghai en à reggane
d'accord pour une conférence sur les
droits de l'homme à moscou elle aurait
lieu en 91 et le président américain a
donné tout à l'heure son approbation
l'attentât contre le boeing de la panam
aujourd'hui une cérémonie à la mémoire
des victimes avaient lieu à lockerbie en
écosse
elle était retransmise en grande
bretagne et aux etats unis voici les
images de cette cérémonie ainsi que
d'autres faits marquants de l'actualité
de ce mercredi olivier dernière l'église
de lockerbie était trop petite margaret
thatcher le directeur de la panam de
nombreux officiels britanniques et
américains et des centaines de proches
des victimes de l'attentât contre le
boeing qui avait explosé le 21 décembre
au dessus de l'ecosse ont assisté à la
cérémonie religieuse donnée à la mémoire
des 270 passagers et membres d'équipage
qui ont péri dans le crash
cent vingt-quatre corps ont pu être
identifiés les avocats des familles des
victimes n'ont pas attendu ses
funérailles pour engager des poursuites
le gouvernement des états unis
et la compagnie aérienne affûtent déjà
leurs arguments pour contre attaquer
le vice ministre soviétique des affaires
étrangères et au pakistan en principe
qu'il devrait rencontrer les chefs des
partis de la résistance afghane
mais entre deux rendez vous qui aurez
voronov a laissé planer un doute sur la
date du retrait des troupes soviétiques
d'afghanistan fixée au 15 février
prochain
un léger report n'est pas exclue cela
dépendra de la situation sur le terrain
avance prudemment youri voronov qui
s'est déjà entretenu ces jours derniers
avec les partis chiites de la résistance
basé en iran
dans la série mikhail gorbatchev reçoit
le numéro un soviétique a tenu à saluer
personnellement le représentant de
l'imam khomeiny ses passages à moscou
l'ayatollah a molli était porteur d'un
message de l'imam khomeiny dont le
contenu n'a pas été dévoilé mais on
suppose qu'il est lié aux multiples
concertations soviétique sur le retrait
des troupes d'afghanistan
hier soir à paris trente trois mille
jeunes rassemblés pour prier c'était la
11e rencontres européennes de taizé à
l'appel de frère roger un quart de ces
jeunes venaient d'europe de l'est
les catholiques de paris c'était bien
sûr mobilisés pour les accueillir et les
recevoir
jean claude barit go pro portage la
place saint sulpice à paris restaurant
universitaire improvisé à six heures du
soir l'un des multiples points de
ralliement de la 11e rencontres
européennes des jeunes de taizé de toute
l'europe ils sont venus en grand nombre
pour répondre à l'appel du frère roger
qui avoue avoir été émerveillé par
l'ampleur du mouvement
puis ce passe-t-il pourquoi vient-il
parce qu'ils savent très bien que via un
tournant de leur vie est aussi un
tournant de l'histoire actuellement à
l'origine chercher l'essentiel l'énergie
bien sûr eu une communion une communion
à dieu mais aussi une solidarité avec la
famille e jets tenons beaucoup beaucoup
solidarité amitié prière autant de mots
entendus et répété pendant la rencontre
à laquelle événements nouveaux ont
participé près de 8000 jeunes en
provenance des pays de l'est
est-ce que c'est difficile d'être
chrétien aujourd'hui congrès ils ne
passent que d'être chrétien c'est très
difficile partout dans le monde
je pense que c'est plus difficile à mon
briquet d'ailleurs mais il n'y a pas de
discrimination je pense que non de moins
en moins dans les dernières années
je pense vraiment
350 paroisse et plusieurs milliers de
parisiens ont ouvert leurs portes à ces
pèlerins d'un nouveau genre qui pour la
plupart découvraient l'ouest pour la
première fois et ça vous fait pas envie
de toutes ces choses qui a dans les
vitrines là
en promo ça nous permet mais nous
n'avons pas d'argent avec ce frère roger
les jeunes de la 11e rencontre
européenne ont conclu à notre dame un
contrat moral celui de contribuer à
faire disparaître tous les bidonvilles
du monde pour l'an 2000
beaucoup de courage en perspective
fêtes de fin d'année c'est à dire aussi
cadeau cadeaux c'est souvent synonyme de
disques et bien justement l'industrie
française du disque est en plein boom un
chiffre d'affaires en augmentation de 34
% cette année le succès du compact disc
n'y ait pas signé foufs le succès du
compact disc y est pour beaucoup voilà
c'est simple
favori du public le rock les variétés le
jazz devant et oui la musique classique
française jolie analyse les raisons de
cette embellie
numéro 1 du top 50 des ventes de disques
en 88
johnny clegg plus d'un million de
disques de cassettes vendue en france
l'an dernier
aucune fausse note non plus dans les
autres genres rock variété jazz et
musique classique là aussi les ventes
sont allées crescendo une envolée de
plus de 34 % en un an
première raison de cette explosion la
baisse de la tva ramenée de 33 3% à 18
6% en décembre 87
me par la piste et ses six mois plus
tard pour parfaire cette harmonie qu'une
deuxième mesure la publicité pour les
disques et les cassettes est autorisé à
la télévision les retombées ont été
extraordinaires puisque on vende un
disque comme édith piaf en temps normal
sans campagne au mieux environ 50000
exemplaires et que l'anneau en somme à
55 cent cinquante mille exemplaires
enfin une des principales clés de ce
boom c'est le succès du disque compact
ses ventes ont été multipliées par deux
l'an dernier mais déjà les industriels
du disque écrivent une nouvelle
partition une deuxième génération de
compact est à l'étude
demain nous sommes jeudi alors il ya un
tiercé quarté + c'est à vincennes voici
les pronostics de carême bresse le 11 le
vin le 17 le 18 le 15
le 4 le 8 et le 14
en quelques instants la météo avec
laurent cabrol henri sannier à 22 eur
puis à 23 heures sera votre informateur
de la soirée à demain